on the next we need to go on a quick and
Mordy Episode six is here let's break it
down so if you didn't know this is rest
and Rick slacks ation the clip is
actually from the cold open it's a
shorter version of the comic-con clip
that they showed off so this is actually
the longer version of that scene that's
so great
what happens after they finished their
adventures like after the celebration is
over it takes its toll so I don't think
this is so much being serialized with
the other episodes but you do see this
cumulative effect of stress on Rick and
Morty like eventually they have to break
even Rick has to break at some point
whatever version of Rick we're looking
at here so the actual episode itself
takes place on this vacation that they
have to take I'm assuming this is the
entire cold open so we're not really
meant to know where they went or what
happened just that it was some crazy
adventure but that green rock that he
stuffs into the box there looks an awful
lot like the green rock from the Mad Max
episode but I like that they actually go
to the school at the beginning of the
clip because it's been a while since
we've done Morty Jessica school stuff he
referenced Jessica in the last episode
like they were talking about their
children he said oh my child's gonna be
beautiful because Jessica's gonna be the
mother I'm sorry I'm not a classic
maternal archetype okay I don't know
what to do when you people come to me
with your weird puberty issues what are
you gonna do when your daughter asks you
if she's attractive I'll say yes Morty
gross well she's gonna be super hot her
mother's gonna be Jessica wait when did
summer ask you that I'm not expecting
too much of the school stuff to be
serialized so it just meant to be like a
random day at school
oh my god Jessica single and if you
relist into that conversation that
they're having as Morty's walking up the
first time I heard foreskin I did a
double-take you have to appreciate how
they're able to casually slip in awkward
teenage humor like that with a really
big sci-fi crazy stuff in the rest of
the clip
Star Wars Return of the Jedi as they
blow up the core you have all these
little creatures that look like sperm
chasing them in the opening in this
giant organic looking ship kind of looks
like a vagina
so you have all these sperm flying it to
this vagina with this little egg in the
middle so they're visual metaphors are
still on point I know we had that
running poop gag like every single
episode has some weird poop jokes
so we'll see what it winds up being in
this episode but I just love this
animation sequence they talked about the
one in last week's episode how there's a
longer version of it and you appreciate
how much work goes into this like they
spent so much time on the scripts that's
what the delays were all about like they
said they just took forever to write it
because they kept trying to write the
better version but we've also learned
the titles and descriptions of the next
couple of episodes so this is episode 6
rest and relaxation
but episode 7 is called tales from the
Citadel it reads Atlantis we're coming a
nice little self-contained episode about
Atlantis is waiting for the audience
episode 8 his title of the ABCs of Beth
obviously a Beth Jeri is lucky with a
lady and Beth recalls her childhood
episode 9 is titled Morty's mind blowers
and it just reads Morty's memory is
restored for this reason we finally
learned the truth in this episode
it doesn't say learn the truth about
what what the secret past is so
presumably that'll be part of the cold
open or they'll just reference it during
the episode in that episode 10 the
finale is called the rick korean morty
date and it says rick goes on a
confrontation with the president that
could either be the president of the
lame government as rick tells it or it
could be this clip here like where we
see with terminator Beth on the
government ship it could be the Galactic
government whoever the new president is
because they have this divorce thing
that's going on they have the Beth
episode they have Morty remembering
things maybe that'll have something to
do with the divorce as well it would
make sense that the finale capped that
off too so it'll have something to do
with it but here's the other big
question - is is will Jeri
reconcile with Beth by the end of the
season or will the divorce spill into
season four they haven't said anything
about whether or not they've started
writing it they just said they have a
plan for Dan Harmon and Justin roiland
before the season started said that
their contracts were up for renewal so
at the time it just sounded like they're
haggling for a better deal but
they already have a plan for season four
so hopefully none of that business stuff
gets in the way of them working on
season four because the sooner they
start the sooner they can get it out to
their animators the sooner we can see it